Couple of questions about dialogue and
engaging in dialogue with people.
So the first issue that I faced is a,
I have a very high need for intellectual
stimulation and I can't get that with
most people.
It's something like you can,
you can have a dialogue for a time,
but then it
titrate openness
and,
and that.
But then they started running out of
ideas they can keep up and it sort of
falls apart and okay,
this is a problem that intellectuals
have quite frequently is that they,
they sort of,
once they started getting difficult and
rewarding stuff,
they stop wanting to talk to regular
people and I think that contributes to
the disconnect that you see between the
intellectuals and working class people
and stuff like that.
And the other question I had was about,
okay,
wait,
I don't know if that's the question.
I believe there's a question in there.
The question is how,
how do you,
how should we address that?
How should I address it?
And uh,
is that something that can be dressed?
Well,
part of,
part of the answer to that is that's
what the universities were for.
I mean,
you know,
not everybody is equipped to or
interested in engaging in high level
discussion of abstract and creative
ideas.
You know,
you hear this idea that everyone's
creative.
That's a lie.
It's a straightforward,
is that true?
Creativity is very,
very rare and so,
and if you happen to be a creative
person or if you happen to be someone
who's profoundly interested in ideas,
you are in a pronounced minority just as
you are,
if you happen to be extremely
extroverted or extremely agreeable,
are extremely conscientious.
These are minority issues and what you
do is you find likeminded people who are
capable of engaging that we know a
heavyweight heavyweight weightlifters
compete with heavyweight weightlifters
for a reason and everyone thinks that's
fine and the same thing applies to
intellectual and creative endeavors.
So what you do is you try to find a
community where that's,
that's the nature of the community and
you likely have to find a relationship
like that as well.
So I don't think so.
I think what contributes to the siloing
is the arrogance that goes along with
it.
Because if you're,
you can be interested in ideas and you
can be creative.
Well that's the arrogance of the
intellect,
right?
That's the thing the Catholic Church had
warned about for centuries is the
arrogance of the intellect.
So because if you're,
if you're wise as well as smart and
there is no relationship between being
smart and being wise,
they are not the same thing.
There is no quick pathway from smart to
wise.
And many of the people who I've known
who were very wise were,
some of them were intellectually
impaired and we're still wise,
you know,
so it's the arrogance that brings up the
block.
And I see this,
for example,
happening in the United States in
particular because the last time I went
down there,
for example,
I was,
I had friends down there and some of
those friends are very,
very smart people and some of them were
talking about the voters and they were
talking about the trump voters with
contempt and I thought you better watch
that because that's 50 percent of the
dam population and it might be
convenient to think that they're stupid
and beneath you,
but it's not conducive to a civil state
and there's no evidence that it's true
because there isn't a straight line
between intelligent and wise.
And so I think that if your,
if your character is developed and
you're intelligent,
you can have your siloed,
creative community,
but you develop enough wisdom so that
you can see all the things that people
can do that or have high ethical utility
that are outside the intellectual
domain.
You know?
And I think that's why in the New
Testament,
I think that's why Christ is a
carpenter,
right?
Because,
well,
first of all,
carpenter is one of those jobs that when
you're dishonest,
it manifests itself immediately because
what you build falls down,
and so if you're an honest carpenter,
you build a good house.
So there's a nice metaphor there,
but it's also.
It's also a warning in some sense
against the the equation of intellectual
brilliance with moral superiority.
And so if the intellects would drop
their moral superiority and fat chance
there is of that,
then that divide between the working
class say and the elite would would
resolve.
And there's every reason to have respect
for decent working class people.
I mean it's on their labor as the left
wingers at least hypothetically agree
that the entire edifice of the culture
is,
is resting so you can have your cake and
eat it too.
But you have to not assume that your
niche makes you superior.
And it's very difficult for smart
people,
especially smart.
There's this scene in niches.
Sins thus spake Zarathustra were zero.
Booster of the profit comes down from
the mountain and he comes into a public
square and there's this crowd around
this little midget who is only about
this high,
who has a gigantic ear and everyone is
marveling at him.
Well,
that's what the modern intellect is
like.
It's a midget with a giant.
Well mouth generally not an ear and the
the,
the being is underdeveloped,
but the intellect is hyper activated and
it makes the person extraordinarily
unbalanced and it's partly because a,
they can't compete outside of the
intellectual realm and that makes them
very bitter because they tend to think,
well,
God,
I'm so smart.
Everything should just come to me.
It's like,
sorry,
that's not how the world works.
And,
and it also that,
that and that,
that,
that attitude is immediately evident to
people that they're talking to when they
talk in the manner that they talk,
if they are arrogant intellectuals of
that sort.
You see that in the simpsons did a good
job of that with Comic Book Guy,
right?
I mean,
he completely useless in every possible
dimension with an Iq of about 160 and
it's very annoying to people who have an
Iq of 160 that they can also be
completely useless,
but it happens a lot.
So yeah.
Thanks.